the people who live nearby joke that
this is where electric vehicles go to
die hundreds of plug-in cars lie
abandoned on the outskirts of Hangzhou
many are around 10 years old previously
owned by companies that didn't survive
in China's fiercely competitive
automotive industry a good portion of
them have been abandoned because there
have been companies that have just
failed and these are kind of the
leftovers leftovers that have created an
embarrassing eyesore for local
authorities this illustrates the kind of
waste that's produced when Supply far
outstrips demand in 2009 the Chinese
government adopted a plan to become a
world leader in electric vehicles
rolling out generous subsidies worth up
to nine thousand dollars per car but
back then most people were reluctant to
switch from petrol-powered Cars so
instead ride hailing companies snapped
them up
in 2019 the government started slashing
those subsidies and hundreds of
companies went bust that's when these
so-called graveyards began to grow since
then automakers have released more
advanced models with Superior driving
range leaving the earlier inferior
models unwanted but some say it points
to the extraordinary progress made by
the sector the Chinese market led the
world for the last few years and uh it's
only distancing itself via the number of
brands in China and the level of
competition it's really really sharpened
the swords of a lot of these Chinese EV
companies or electric vehicle companies
about a third of
trick and sixty percent of the world's
battery-powered cars are sold in China
but sputtering economic growth here this
year has hurt sales it's pushed Chinese
Brands such as byd and Neo to expand in
Europe and the Middle East with hopes
that their cars will avoid the same fate
as these
katrinau Al Jazeera Hangzhou
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera